AARON RODGERS.
LOOK, IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO BE AT OR NEAR THE TOP,
WE TALKED ABOUT MILES UNTIL
IT GETS RESOLVED. NOW, ONE
THING I'VE NOTICED,
MOVING POSSIBLY.
TOWARD AS IT RELATES TO THIS
IS
IT LOOKS LIKE GUYS WHO KNOW
HIM AND WHO HAVE TALKED TO
THE FORMER FULLBACK OF THE ,
PACKERS OR JAMES JONES, THE
FORMER RECEIVER, WHO PLAYED
WITH RODGERS AND THE PACKERS
THEY'RE POTENTIALLY SERVING
AS SURROGATES.
TO GET OUT.
OUT THIS IDEA THAT THIS IS
AND IT'S ALL OVERBLOWN AND
THIS MAY BE THE BEGINNINGS OF
THE AARON RODGERS BACKPEDAL.
AND AN EFFORT. IF HE DOESN'T
A TRADE TO SHOW UP AND PLAY
FOR GREEN BAY FOR ANOTHER
YEAR BECAUSE THEY REALLY DO
HAVE THEM IN A BOX. AND THIS
AND I STARTED MAKING T SIMS
AND I HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO
THE IDEA THAT FROM THE
PACKERS PERSPECTIVE, IF THIS
GUY WANTS TO RETIRE, SO BE IT.
SO BE IT WILL TAKE BACK 30
MILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU HAVE
ALREADY BEEN PAID, WILL
AVOID GIVING YOU FOURTEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION IN SALARY
THIS YEAR AND SO BE IT FINE,
YOU DON'T WANT TO PLAY FINE
AND MAYBE THAT'S ACTUALLY
BETTER FOR THE PEOPLE WHO RUN
THE TEAM THAN IT IS TO TRADE
HIM BECAUSE NO MATTER HOW
MANY DRAFT PICKS YOU GET
AARON. RODGERS IS STILL GOING
TO PLAY FOR SOMEONE ELSE.
AND MAKE YOU LOOK BAD FOR
WINNING A SUPER BOWL AND E BY
MATCHING THE NUMBER HE WON IN
16 YEARS AT THE PACKERS OR
MAYBE BY WINNING TWO, OR
MAYBE AFTER TWO OR THREE
YEARS, THE TEAM THAT HE'S
PLAYING FOR RELEASES HIM AND
HE ENDS UP WITH THE VIKINGS
OR THE BEARS AND THE LIONS.
NOT THAT THAT'S
UNPRECEDENTED AS IT RELATES
TO A FORMER PACKERS
QUARTERBACK. SO I THINK HE'S
NUMBER ONE, THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BUDGE NUMBER TWO. THEY MAY
PREFER RETIREMENT TO TRADING
HIM. SO NUMBER THREE, HE
CAN MOONWALK HIS WAY RIGHT
BACK INTO LAMBEAU FIELD. AND
I THINK THAT THE STUFF FROM
KHUN AND JONES POSSIBLY IS
THAT THAT SIGNAL THAT THAT'S
WHAT MAY HAPPEN. SURE. LOOK,
IF THAT'S THE CASE, THEN
GREAT. BUT, YOU KNOW, I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT. THAT YOU
ESSENTIALLY THESE GUYS SEEM
TO BE FUNCTIONING AS
SURROGATES AND IT'S ALMOST
MOST LIKE, YOU KNOW, YOU'RE
TUNING IN TO CABLE NEWS AND
YOU'RE WATCHING SOMEBODY TALK
FOR A POLITICIAN. IT'S A
LITTLE BIT WEIRD WHEN IT
COMES TO AN ATHLETE
ESPECIALLY WHEN THAT ATHLETE
HAS PLENTY OF PLATFORMS TO GO
ON AND JUST SPEAK FOR HIMSELF,
RIGHT? I THINK, YOU KNOW,
SPEAK FOR HIMSELF, RIGHT? I
THINK, YOU KNOW, MIKE EVEN
SAYING THIS I THINK FOR THE
LAST WEEK THAT WE PROBABLY
NEED TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM
AARON RODGERS, AND I THINK
DIRECTLY FROM AARON RODGERS
AND I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
PROBABLY CLEAR A LOT OF THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS UP. THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S
AND IS AARON RODGERS, WANT TO
GET THE GM FIRED AND NOW IT
SEEMS LIKE, OH, YOU KNOW,
THIS THING IS GONNA BACK OFF
A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT JAMES JONES IS SAYING.
AND THAT'S WHAT JUNCTIONS,
AND IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT ALL
OF THAT. IT'S MORE. THAT
AARON RODGERS HAS ISSUES. YES,
BUT THEY ARE FIXABLE. IF
THAT'S THE CASE, LET'S HEAR
FROM AARON RODGERS. LET'S
HEAR HIM SAY IT. AND I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY
VALUABLE FOR EVERYBODY
INVOLVED. BECAUSE IF HE
REALLY DOES WANT TO GET BACK
WITH THE PACKERS, MIKE, THEN
THAT'S GOING TO BE A GOOD.
AVENUE TO TRY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN OR IF HE REALIZES THAT
HE HAS TO BE BACK WITH THE
PACKERS, THEN HIM SAYING
SOMETHING. ANYTHING IS
PROBABLY GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HELP THAT.
AND IF HE KEEPS HIS MOUTH
SHUT AND THE SURROGATES
CONTINUE TO PERIODICALLY SAY
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING FOR, AS
LONG AS MEDIA WILL BE SEEKING
THEM OUT. THEN WHEN ROGERS
DOES SHOW UP, HE CAN JUST
KIND OF SHRUG AND THAT KIND
OF LOOSE. CALM. YEAH. YOU
KNOW, THERE'S ALWAYS THINGS
THAT WE DISCUSSED AND THERE'S
ALWAYS DISAGREEMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE IN A RELATIONSHIP THAT
LASTS THIS LONG. AND I THINK
THE MEDIA MADE TOO MUCH OF IT
AND KIND OF LIKE WHAT HE DID.
LISTEN.
DON'T WASTE YOUR TIME READING
THAT CRAP, BUT YES, EXACTLY
LAST TIME. THIS THIS FIRE
STARTED, HE PUT IT OUT TWO
DAYS LATER. I JUST THINK
THAT HE'S HE'S PUT HIMSELF IN
A WEIRD, KIND OF A SPOT HERE,
MAYBE IT'LL DIE DOWN, MAYBE
MAYBE IT'S SOME POINT. WE
TURN THE PAGE AT SOME POINT.
WE TURN THE PAGE AT SOME
POINT. SOMETHING ELSE IS
GOING TO HAPPEN. THAT IS
GOING TO CAPTURE OUR
ATTENTION. AND AT THAT POINT,
MAYBE THIS JUST FIZZLES OUT
HE SHOWS UP FOR OFFSEASON
WORKOUTS OTAS, MANDATORY
YOU KNOW, WITHIN THE NEXT
MONTH OR SO WE'LL KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT HE'S TAKING AN
AGGRESSIVE POSTURE, WE DON'T
HAVE TO WAIT FOR TRAINING
CAMP, MANDATORY MINICAMP. IF
HE'S NOT THERE, THAT'S OUR
SIGN THAT SOMETHING'S GOING
ON. SO, I JUST THINK AND I
THAT I TRUST THAT I'VE SPOKEN
TO ABOUT THIS AND WE KIND OF
KICK AROUND IDEAS. THERE IS A
SENSE THAT HE'S JUST GOING TO
ACT LIKE
THIS IS NO BIG DEAL ONCE.
A LOT OF THESE INNER CORNER
AND HE'S NOT WILLING TO WRITE
A CHECK FOR 30 MILLION
DOLLARS AND GIVE UP FOOTBALL
BEFORE HE'S READY TO GIVE UP
FOOTBALL. IF THE CHOICE IS
OUR PLAY FOR US, PLAY FOR NO
ONE, HE'S GOING TO PLAY FOR
US, HE'S NOT GOING TO GO HOME,
TAKE HIS FOOTBALL AND GIVE
BACK, NEARLY 30 MILLION
DOLLARS TO GREEN BAY PACKERS
INCORPORATED BECAUSE THEY'LL
HAPPILY TAKE IT. AND I THINK
YOU COULD ARGUE IT IS BETTER
TO GET THE 30 MILLION AND NOT
HAVING PLAY THAN IT IS TO GET
TWO MILLION AND HAVE TO WATCH
HIM PLAY IN WORRIED ABOUT
WHAT HE'S GONNA DO AND
WORRIED. HE'S GOING TO END UP
BACK IN THE NFC NORTH MILES.
AND, YOU KNOW, I ANOTHER
PIECE OF EVIDENCE IN THIS
RUNDOWN BUT I WANT TO MENTION
IT, CHEF T-TRYING TO WALK
BACK, THE IDEA THAT HE GOT
THE INFORMATION. LAST
IT'S CLAIMING THAT HE ALREADY
HAD IT WHEN HIS TWEET AND HIS
STORY BOTH SAID LEAGUE AND
SEEM TEAM SOURCES TOLD ME ON
THURSDAY OR WHATEVER. WHY?
THAT LOOK
AN EFFORT, A BROADER EFFORT,
THINK TO MAKE AARON RODGERS
, LOOK BETTER THAN THE
SITUATION TO DATE. HAS MADE
HIM LOOK AND WHETHER IT'S
COONS COMMENTS, WHETHER IT'S
JONES COMMENTS, WHETHER IT'S
SHIFTY TRYING TO MAKE HIS
YOU KNOW, AND EFFORT BY
ROGERS AND HIS CAMP TO GET
THIS OUT ON DRAFT DAY, WHICH
I FIRMLY BELIEVE THIS IS ALL
SETTING THE STAGE FOR ROGERS
TO KIND OF DO THE WHAT'S THE
BIG DEAL?
YEAH, IT IS, BUT I THINK WE
CAN EVEN GO BACK TO SATURDAY
AT THE KENTUCKY DERBY WHEN
MIKE TIRICO SAID THAT HE
SPOKE TO AARON RODGERS AND
AARON SAID THAT HE, HE, HE
TREECKO CHARACTERIZED HIM AS
BEING DISAPPOINTED, THAT THE
STORY HAD GOTTEN OUT IN THAT
THIS SORT OF SEEMS TO GO INTO
THAT THAT THOUGHT THAT AARON
RODGERS WANTS TO BE THOUGHT
OF IN A GOOD LIGHT AT LEAST
BY PACKERS FANS. BECAUSE OF
COURSE, YOU REMEMBER TO
RECONNECT,
OH, EVEN SAID THAT AARON
RODGERS. EMPHASIZE HOW MUCH
HE LOVES THE PACKERS FANS AND
HOW MUCH HE LOVED HIS
EXPERIENCE PLAYING IN GREEN
BAY AND THINGS LIKE THAT. SO
AGAIN, I THINK THAT WITH ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT AVENUES THAT
THERE ARE FOUR PLAYERS TO SAY
WHAT IT IS THAT THEY WANT TO
SAY IN THESE DAYS. ALL AARON
RODGERS HAS TO DO WAS LIKE,
TURN ON HIS PHONE AND MAKE A
TWO-MINUTE VIDEO, RIGHT? JJ
WATT. DID THAT WHEN THE
TEXANS RELEASED HIM AND
YOU'RE GONNA LOOK AT ANY
YOUTUBE STAR IN THE WORLD,
RIGHT? ALL THEY DO IS THEY
AND THEN THEY SAY WHATEVER IT
IS THEY WANT TO SAY DOES NOT,
LIKE AARON HAS TO GO TO SOME
NEWS OUTLET AND SAY, HEY I
WANT TO DO AN INTERVIEW THAT
HE CAN DO, WHATEVER HE WANTS
TO DO ON HIS OWN, AND IN HIS
OWN TIME. I JUST, I FEEL LIKE
AT THIS POINT, IF HE REALLY
WANTS TO TAMPER THINGS DOWN
AND TURN THE TEMPERATURE DOWN
THESE THINGS, JUST SAY IT
YEAH. AND AND THAT THAT VIDEO,
IF HE WOULD MAKE ONE WOULD
VIEWS JUST LIKE THAT. AND
AGAIN, TIRICO ALSO SAID
THERE IS A FISSURE THERE IS A
FISSURE THERE IS A CHASM
BETWEEN ROGERS AND THE FRONT